[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Marietta Slomka guten
Abend die EU will mit Tunesien ein
flüchtlingsabkommen Schließen von der
Idee her ähnlich wie der Deal den es mit
der Türkei gab und mit ein Problem
gleich schon benannt ist es gibt keine
Garantie dass solche Abkommen auf Dauer
funktionieren bei Tunesien stellen sich
aber noch andere Fragen wir sprechen
darüber gleich auch noch
eu-kommissionschefin Ursula von der
Leyen reiste nicht allein nach Tunis mit
dabei waren heute unter anderem die
italienische Regierungschefin Meloni an
ihr lässt sich gut sehen wie schwierig
die Flüchtlingspolitik in der Realität
ist im Wahlkampf hatte sie wie alle
Rechtspopulisten das Blaue vom Himmel
versprochen tatsächlich sind an Italiens
Küsten in diesem Jahr aber schon mehr
als doppelt so viele Flüchtlinge
angekommen wie im gleichen Zeitraum des
Feuers
Florian
es sollte nur eine Durchgangsstation
sein jetzt campieren sie hier seit
Monaten ein Lager in Tunis irgendwie
haben sie sich eingerichtet die meisten
wollen nicht mit uns reden Mohammed
schon er kam aus Guinea Westafrika er
will nach Europa
ich werde übers Meer nach Deutschland
kommen ich habe das schon einmal
versucht da hat uns die Küstenwache
zurückgebracht
es ist wirklich nicht einfach
er will es wieder versuchen sagt uns
Mohammed und sie wollen das gern
verhindern Team Europa heute auf
Kurzbesuch in Tunesien schon zum zweiten
Mal in vier Wochen heute aber mit
Unterschrift unter einen flüchtlingsdeal
zumindest unter die erste Grundsatz
Vereinbarung
wichtiges Ergebnis mit dem tunesischen
Präsidenten erzielt
ein weiterer Schritt hin zu einer echten
Partnerschaft zwischen Tunesien und der
Europäischen Union
Europäer europa hat ein Problem
steigende Flüchtlingszahlen Druck von
rechts in fast jedem Land gestern wieder
erreichen hunderte geflüchtete die
italienische insellampedusa die Menschen
hier kommen aus ganz Afrika ihr Boot aus
Tunesien jetzt verspricht dieses
Tunesien Flüchtlinge an der Ausreise zu
hindern abgewiesene wieder aufzunehmen
im Gegenzug winkt Europa mit Geld fast
eine Milliarde Euro und setzt sich dafür
mit einem Mann an den Tisch der wie ein
Diktator Auftritt Tunesiens Präsident
das ist ein Präsident der in den
vergangenen zwei Jahren systematisch
alle demokratischen Institutionen ähm
abgebaut hat das ist sehr problematisch
kommt dabei hinzu das ist auch ein
Präsident ist der ausgesprochen
rassistisch ist gegenüber subsahara
Afrikanern und Afrikanerinnen Bilder von
vor ein paar Tagen die tunesische
Küstenwache hat diese geflüchteten
offenbar in der Grenze zwischen Tunesien
und Libyen ausgesetzt ohne Hilfe ohne
Trinkwasser die EU drückt beide Augen zu
und verliert dazu heute kein Wort in der
Pressekonferenz in der keine Fragen
erlaubt sind bloß eine Floskel die
Erinnerung an geltendes Recht
wir wollen beim Grenzschutz
zusammenarbeiten beim Kampf gegen
Schmuggler bei der Rückkehr dem Kampf
gegen Fluchtursachen in vollem Respekt
des internationalen rechtss
und der tunesische Präsident verspricht
man Arbeiter an einer Zukunft in der
jeder Mensch seine Träume erreichen
könne
sollten Sie in diesem Lager irgendwann
davon erfahren es dürfte sich wie hohen
anhören gemeint sind sie jedenfalls
nicht
darüber wollen wir mit Gerald Knaus
sprechen Migrationsforscher und
Gründungsdirektor des Think Tanks
europäische stabilitätsinitiative guten
Abend Herr Knaus guten Abend sie sind ja
eigentlich ein großer Verfechter solche
Abkommen sie haben mit zum Beispiel auch
das Abkommen mit der Türkei maßgeblich
selbst auch mitgeprägt dann müsste
eigentlich ja so eine Absichtserklärung
wie heute oder Grundsatzerklärung in
ihrem Sinne sein oder
naja die entscheidende Frage ist handelt
es sich hier um etwas das an die Türkei
Erklärung von 2016 erinnert oder ist das
ein wiederbeleben der Art Kooperation
wie sie Italien seit 2017 mit Libyen
verfolgt im zweiten Fall war es eine
Politik die im Grunde genommen mit Geld
eine Regierung in Tripoli aber auch
direkt zum Teil die Schmuggler besticht
und die dann darauf setzt dass diese mit
egal welchen Methoden wir schauen nicht
so genau hin Menschen daran hindert
abzufahren oder sie auf dem Meer stoppt
und zurück bringt und was dann für
Gräueltaten in Libyen passiert sind seit
2017 seit dem Beginn dieser Politik bis
heute das ist sehr gut dokumentiert also
die entscheidende Frage ist nicht ist es
gut Abkommen zu haben die entscheidende
Frage ist was steht in diesen Abkommen
drinnen geht es da auch um die
Menschenrechte derjenigen die gestoppt
werden sollen und ja was ist das
eigentlich Ziel der Europäischen Union
durch Terror Menschen abzuhalten der
dann durch andere Staaten ausgeführt
wird oder durch Kooperation wirklich auf
der Grundlage des Rechts naja man kann
natürlich Menschen rechnen so ein
Abkommen reinschreiben aber ob sich dann
da irgendjemand dran hält weiß man nicht
also wenn man sieht dass da Leute ohne
Wasser und Lebensmittel in der Wüste
ausgesetzt werden da kann man ja sich
ungefähr vorstellen wie wirkungsvoll das
ist wenn man dann den Präsidenten der
auch zunehmend diktatorisch regiert
autokratisch regiert sagt und nun sei
doch bitte mal einen Menschenfreund ja
und vor allem da diese Ereignisse in den
letzten Wochen während parallel zu den
Verhandlungen stattfanden also diese
Idee Leute an die Wüsten Grenzen zu
bringen sowohl zur Grenze mit Libyen er
sagt zur Grenze mit Algerien das haben
wir in den letzten Wochen immer wieder
gesehen und auch die Verfolgung der der
Rassismus der vom Präsidenten
angestachelt wurde durch seine Reden in
Tunesien der lässt böses erwarten das
heißt nicht dass wir nicht reden sollten
mit Tunesien über gewisse Dinge also das
Tunesien etwa Magnesia schneller
zurücknimmt und wir im Gegenzug legale
Wege anbieten das Tunesien nicht mehr in
die Boote steigen darüber kann man
legitime Abkommen machen man kann die
Tunesien haben ja wahrscheinlich auch
Gründe dass immer mehr Tunesier auch
selbst kommen also nicht Afrikaner aus
subsahara Afrika sondern tunesische
Landsleute dienen solche Boote steigen
Tunesier waren in den letzten Jahren die
größte Gruppe in diesem Jahr ist es die
drittgrößte Gruppe bis jetzt die hier in
die Boote stiegen allerdings ganz wenige
von ihnen werden am Ende als Flüchtlinge
anerkannt es gibt in Tunesien Verfolgung
es gibt Parlamentarier Journalisten
AktivistInnen die im Gefängnis sind aber
das sind selten die Menschen die sich in
diese Boote setzen hier die irreguläre
Migration im Einklang mit
europäischen Rechts zu reduzieren indem
man sagt man macht schnelle Verfahren
man bringt Tunesien schnell zurück dafür
öffnet man legale Wege wie das
Griechenland im letzten Jahr in einem
abkönig Bangladesch beispielsweise macht
also da werden legale Wege jedes Jahr
einige tausend Plätze geboten das ist
legitim nur ist das keine Lösung für die
Menschen aus Elfenbeinküste oder Guinea
nun gibt es ja auch nicht unbegrenzt
Anrainer Staaten am Mittelmeer also man
kann sich die Player mit denen man es
dazu tun hat ja auch nur bedingt
aussuchen in meine wenn man sich das
ansieht Tunesien Algerien Libyen gibt es
da überhaupt noch geeignete Drittstaaten
für solche flüchtlingsdeals also
zunächst muss man sagen die Vorstellung
dass man nicht tunesia
zurückbringt nach Tunesien ist sowieso
ausgeschlossen das würde nur
funktionieren wie im Falle Libyens dass
der Europäische Union mit der
tunesischen Küstenwache indirekt
kooperiert und die bringen die Leute
zurück und da wie gesagt haben wir
gesehen dass die Menschenrechtslage dann
eine katastrophal ist nein die die
einzige Möglichkeit hier voranzukommen
wäre auf sichere Drittstaaten zu setzen
die nicht notwendigerweise in Nordafrika
liegen und da ist das Problem der
deutschen Politik das ist hier keinen
Konsens gibt man ist dagegen zu
versuchen andere Staaten dabei zu
unterstützen sicher zu sein
also hier ist die Frage kann man mit
anderen Staaten Abkommen schließen die
dann erlauben dass dort Asylverfahren
stattfinden dann müsste man Menschen
nicht mehr nach Libyen zurückbringen und
würde trotzdem Menschen dabei entmutigen
in diese tödlichen Boote zu steigen aber
dafür gibt es eine gute derzeit keinen
Konsistenz sagt der Migrationsforscher
Gerald Knaus danke für das Gespräch ich
danke Ihnen
ob es gelingt das flüchtlingsabkommen
mit der Türkei irgendwann wieder zu
beleben Fragezeichen wird man sehen der
türkische Präsident ist auf
internationaler Bühne ja eh ein eher
unberechenbarer Player einerseits
blockte er ewig und drei Tage die
Aufnahme Schwedens in die NATO
andererseits bietet er Putin beim
getreideabkommen mit der Ukraine gekonnt
die Stirn das läuft morgen aus ein
zynischer Poker ums Brot für die Welt
doch Pokern kann Erdogan gut vielleicht
schafft er es ja da eine Einigung
herauszuhandeln jeder internationale
Erfolg ist für ihn auch innenpolitisch
wichtig in der Rolle des Weltenlenkers
vom Bosporus sieht er sich jedenfalls
gern wie zuletzt beim nato-gipfelbericht
Auftritt Recep Tayyip Erdogan bei der
NATO am Dienstag im Kreise Jena
westlichen Führer die der türkische
Präsident immer wieder quälte mit neuen
Wolken harscher Kritik unkonventionellen
Entscheidungen und überraschenden
Forderungen wie dieser
zuerst ebnet ihr den Weg für die Türkei
in die Europäische Union und dann eben
wir den Weg Schwedens in die NATO so wie
wir das schon mit Finnland gemacht haben
sprachs und stimmte tags darauf dem
NATO-Beitritt Schwedens zu auch ohne
vorher EU-Mitglied geworden zu sein alle
atmeten auf hinter Erdogans Großmut aber
so vermuten viele Städte wie stets
allein pragmatisches Kalkül
ischen ist die Motivation ist die
Beziehungen zum Westen zu normalisieren
damit diese dann der Motor werden
verengere Wirtschaftsbeziehungen der
Türkei mit dem Westen
denn Investoren braucht das Land der
Wiederaufbau nach dem verheerenden
Erdbeben vom Februar soll geschätzt rund
100 Milliarden Euro kosten Erdogan
Umgang neben Russland auch arabische
Staaten wie Katar um auch dort die
Beziehungen zu verbessern und
Finanzspritzen für seine darbende
Wirtschaft locker zu machen
Emirate und Russland werden es jedoch
nicht allein schaffen das Defizit in der
türkischen Wirtschaft auszugleichen das
entstanden ist durch den Verfall der
türkischen Lira und den Anstieg der
Inflation
das Volk echt weiter unter den hohen
Preisen ausgelöst auch durch die
unorthodoxe Finanzpolitik des
Präsidenten der setzte bislang auf
niedrige Kreditzinsen wo doch alle Welt
auf hohe Zinsen setzt um Inflation zu
bekämpfen nun versucht Erdogan offenbar
umzustellen
die Regierung geht zurück auf Start um
mehr Investitionen der Europäer und
westlicher Länder zu bekommen und ihren
Kurs fortsetzen zu können
Beobachter aber warnen vor allzu großer
Vorfreude so soll das türkische
Parlament erst im Oktober über den
schwedischen NATO-Beitritt abstimmen bis
dahin könnten sich Stimmungen auch
wieder ändern
die Zustimmung des Parlaments ist alles
andere als garantiert vor allem wenn in
der Zwischenzeit wieder unschöne Dinge
in Schweden passieren
wie weitere Koranverbrennungen oder
ähnliches dann könnte es mit der neuen
Freundschaft zumindest vorübergehend
auch wieder vorbei sein
die USA haben heute noch mal betont dass
auch die Ukraine in die NATO gehöre
Sicherheitsberater Jack Sullivan sagt in
einem Interview die Zukunft des Landes
liege in der NATO das sei auch nicht
mehr verhandelbar das ist insofern ein
interessanter Satz weil es ja
Vermutungen gibt Washington und Berlin
würden eine NATO Mitgliedschaft der
Ukraine als Teil einer Verhandlungsmasse
in der Hinterhand behalten wenn es dann
irgendwann zu Verhandlungen mit Russland
kommt
danach sieht es im Moment nicht aus der
Krieg wird weiter mit voller Herze
geführt wie brutal das ist erleben auch
Deutsche die als Helfer in die Ukraine
kommen unsere Porter daran hat zwei
deutsche Ärzte getroffen die an der
Front helfen
wir fahren in den Don Bass in slowjansk
sind wir mit zwei deutschen Ärzten
verabredet die verwundete Menschen
Zivilisten wie Soldaten aus dem
Frontgebiet evakuieren freiwillig und
unentgeltlich sie kämpfen gerade mit
allem was sie haben für das was sie
haben und das ist für mich extrem
beeindruckend gewesen das zu sehen
Bastian arbeitet in Deutschland als
Unfallchirurg jetzt ist der für vier
Wochen freiwilliger Arzt bei der
Hilfsorganisation road for release die
zentrale wirkt wie eine große WG
Lagebesprechung am Küchentisch es geht
um ihren letzten Einsatz
am nächsten Tag treffen wir die beiden
wieder acht Kilometer von der Front
entfernt die Rettungsfahrzeuge sind
getarnt versteckt unter Bäumen
nicht nur ihre Einsätze auch das Warten
ist im Krieg gefährlich
wenn sich die panzerrampe hinten öffnet
und du weißt nicht ganz genau wie viel
tote da drin liegen
in welchem Zustand
tust du dann verpacken und im dümmsten
Fall unter der batteriebeschuss das ist
keine schöne Erfahrung und auch die
Verletzungen die man dann da sieht die
sind
die sieht man sonst habe ich bis jetzt
noch nicht gesehen heute ist es ruhig an
der Front deshalb dürfen wir kurz
mitfahren bis zu sechs Verletzte können
Sie notfalls im Rettungswagen aufnehmen
und ich am am Ding festhält so dass du
nicht umknickst wir haben Patienten
behandeln das ist am Anfang ein bisschen
gewöhnungsbedürftig weil du
bewegungseingeschränkt bist aber dafür
nicht um
ganz gut soweit für verwundete Soldaten
sind Rettungskräfte die letzte
Überlebens Chance die geldverkonvention
verbietet zwar Angriffe auf medizinische
Einheiten doch die russische Armee
beschießt sie gezielt
wir veränderten unseren Standort schon
zweimal sie haben unsere Position
ausgekundschaftet und mit Artillerie
beschossen
folgende Idee tötet man Militärärzte
gibt es mehr Tote und die Moral an der
Front singt
Militärtechnik stimmt das sogar
hier haben Bastian und Peter in den
letzten vier Wochen die Zeit zwischen
den Einsätzen verbracht doch auch
slovanz ist eine Stadt unter Beschuss
die meisten Einwohner sind geflüchtet
es ist trotzdem leben hier sind
Geschäfte offen du kannst ganz normal
bummeln gehen aber
viele Leute sind einfach weg sie seien
froh dass ihr Einsatz jetzt vorüber sei
sagen die beiden zumindest Bastian würde
wiederkommen allerdings nur wenn seine
Frau erneut einverstanden sein sollte
und jetzt macht erst mal Hanna
Zimmermann weiter mit anderen
Nachrichten an diesem Sonntag immer mehr
Rentnerinnen und Rentner in Deutschland
sind auf Grundsicherung angewiesen mit
mehr als
684.000 waren das Ende März so viele wie
noch nie das berichtet die Funke
Mediengruppe unter Berufung auf noch
nicht veröffentlichte Daten des
Statistischen Bundesamts im Vergleich
zum Vorjahr steht die Zahl der Menschen
die Grundsicherung beziehen demnach um
etwa 15 Prozent grund dafür seien auch
ukrainische geflüchtete die Anspruch auf
die Leistung haben
Iran hat die Rückkehr der sogenannten
Sittenpolizei verkündet diese soll ab
heute wieder die Kopftuchpflicht
kontrollieren und Verstöße dagegen
bestrafen der Tod der Kurve nie in
Gewahrsam der moralpolizei hatte im
vergangenen Jahr landesweite
regimekritische Proteste ausgelöst und
Zuge dessen waren die Patrouillen von
der Straße verschwunden und immer mehr
Frauen zeigten sich ohne Kopftuch in der
Öffentlichkeit
der
us-klimaschutzbeauftragte carrie ist zu
Gesprächen in China eingetroffen sein
dreitägiger Besuch hat zum Ziel die
wegen politischer Spannungen
ausgesetzten Klimaverhandlungen wieder
aufzunehmen die USA und China sind die
beiden größten CO2 Emittenten der Welt
und entscheidend im Kampf gegen den
Klimawandel Beobachter messen dem Besuch
hohen symbolischen Wert bei carry ist
das dritte Mitglied der US-Regierung das
binnen weniger Wochen die Volksrepublik
besucht
nach mehreren Gewalttaten in Berliner
Freibädern wird über die Konsequenzen
diskutiert linken Parteichefin Wissler
wie ist die Forderung des designierten
cdu-generalsekretärinemann nach
Eilverfahren am Tag zurück dies sei
Blanca Populismus und mit
rechtsstaatlichen Verfahren nicht zu
vereinbaren sagte sie in der ARD grünen
Chef nuripur erklärte im ZDF war ein
schnelles Eingreifen wäre gut doch ist
viele Personal auch bei der Polizei sein
zu viele Stellen unter CDU-Führung
abgebaut worden
sommerinterview hat sich grünen Chef
nuripur ausführlich zur Lage seiner
Partei geäußert die Grünen stecken hier
an einem Dilemma einerseits haben sie
mit ihrem Ehrgeiz beim heizungsgesetz
viele Bürger verunsichert und vor den
Kopf gestoßen auf der anderen Seite wird
ihnen von der eigenen Basis übel
genommen wenn sie sich in der
Ampelkoalition pragmatisch zeigen bzw
nicht durchsetzen könnten diese
Ernüchterung zeigt sich auch in
Parteiaustritten
mit einer Analyse wo stehen die Grünen
nach gut anderthalb Jahren regieren
auf Sommertour vor ein paar Stunden
startet der Grünen Parteivorsitzende
sein Programm für die nächsten Wochen
Bürgergespräche Diskussionsrunden
wählerkontakt die eigene Politik
erklären das scheint bei den Grünen
gerade sehr nötig die Partei hat
katastrophale Monate hinter sich im ZDF
sommerinterview sucht nur nach
Erklärungen fürs grüne tief
es ist richtig dass die Grünen sehr viel
wollen und es ist richtig dass wir der
Meinung sind dass die Vorsorge in diesem
Land nicht zu kurz kommen darf das alles
ein Marathon am Ende wird abgerechnet
auf der Wegstrecke seit letztem Sommer
haben die Grünen stark verloren in
Umfragen von 26 auf 16 % Grund auch eine
Serie politischer Niederlagen
Verkehrspolitik regelt die FDP für die
Kinder Grundsicherung gibt es weniger
Geld der grüne Klimaschutz enttäuscht
Umweltverbände und das heizungsgesetz
wird zum Horror für Robert habe Weg wir
sehen eigentlich bei den Grünen seit
vielen Jahren an die Lämmer nämlich das
ist eine abstrakte Zustimmung zu mehr
Klimaschutz gibt aber wenn es dann darum
geht es runter zu brechen was heißt das
denn für das Leben von Menschen dann
fällt es Ihnen regelmäßig schwer auch
dafür Zustimmung zu generieren das war
beim veggy day der Fall das war mal beim
Benzinpreis der Fall es ist jetzt bei
den Heizungen der Fall man sei die
letzte Regierung die den Klimawandel
noch eindämmen könne damit haben die
Grünen zwei Jahren Wahlkampf gemacht
eine kompromisslose Ansage jetzt in der
regierungsrealität aber ist man auf
Kompromisse angewiesen am Freitag setzt
der Bundeskanzler eine hohe Hürde für
die künftige Klimapolitik meine
Überzeugung ist wer zum Beispiel
Klimapolitik machen will muss sich
zutrauen dass jeder einzelne gesetzliche
Regelung in den erfolgsabstimmung eine
Mehrheit fände nuripur hat daran Zweifel
und erinnert die SPD an ihre eigene
Historie die Sozialdemokratie hat in
ihre verdienstvollen Geschichte über 150
Jahre immer wieder Themen auf die
Tagesordnung gesetzt auf den Tisch
gepackt die nicht mehr als wie ich waren
und hat dafür gekämpft sie mehr zu
machen schmerzhaft für die Grünen in
aktuellen Umfragen liegt die AFD 4%
Punkte vor ihnen 19% der deutschen sagen
die Grünen sein selbst schuld daran die
Partei sei der Hauptgrund für das
Erstarken der AFD die der
Verfassungsschutz als in Teilen
gesichert rechtsextreme einstuft
nicht so dass frühere grüne Wählerinnen
und Wähler jetzt die AFD wählen dafür
ist die Distanz zwischen den Parteien
sehr sehr groß aber dass sie diese
Ängste produzieren mit ihren Themen das
kann man sich schon vorstellen die AFD
bietet dir keine Lösungen die AFD ist
eher dabei Deutschland immer nur
schlecht zu reden und davon wollen sie
profitieren erst recht in dieser
Situation ist es notwendig dass die
demokratischen Parteien zusammenstehen
nur meint Friedrich Merz der seine
Partei zum Hauptgegner erklärt hat es
sind schwere Monate für die Grünen
Weltverbesserer möchten Sie sein gerade
aber sind sie Wut Magnet
zumindestens das Thema Klimawandel mit
den Grünen erhalten bleiben mit dem
aktuellen Extremwetter geht es jetzt bei
dir weiter ja extreme Hitze hält
weiterhin große Teile der nördlichen
Erdhalbkugel fest im Griff in Asien den
USA und Europa haben die Behörden
vielerorts hitzewarnungen ausgegeben
denn die hohen Temperaturen können für
Risikogruppen lebensbedrohlich werden
auf der Knarren Insel da Palma kämpfen
hunderte Feuerwehrleute gegen einen
Waldbrand der innerhalb eines Tages
knapp 4.700 Hektar zerstört hat mehr als
4000 Menschen mussten in Sicherheit
gebracht werden inzwischen erleichtern
die Wetterbedingungen die Löscharbeiten
nach schweren Überschwemmungen und
Erdrutschen in Südkorea ist die Zahl der
Todesopfer auf 37 gestiegen dutzende
Straßen und Häuser wurden nach
tagelangen heftigen Regenfällen von
Wasser und Schlammmassen zerstört fast
9000 Menschen mussten die betroffenen
Gebiete verlassen Südkorea steckten
mitten in der Monsunzeit der
Wetterdienst rechnet mit weiteren
schweren Regenfällen
zum Sport bei der Schwimm-WM in Japan
bleiben die deutschen Schwimmer auf
Erfolgskurs Weltmeister im
Freiwasserschwimmen über 10 km wurde
Florian Wellbrock vor dem Ungarn
Christoph raschowski Bronze
gegenüberraschend an den Frankfurter
Oliver Clement der sich damit ebenso wie
Wellbrock die Olympia Teilnahme
gesichert hat
carlos hat das Grand Slam Turnier von
Wimbledon gewonnen im Finale des Rasen
Tennis Klassiker siegte der 20-Jährige
Spanier gegen den fast 16 Jahre älteren
werden Novak Djokovic in fünf Sätzen für
alcaras war es der erste Sieg in
Wimbledon mit einem Triumph verteidigte
er außerdem Platz 1 in der Weltrangliste
[Applaus]
eine Engländerin die zu einer Ikone
Frankreichs wird das muss man erst mal
schaffen selbst der französische
Präsident trauert heute öffentlich um
Sie Jane Birkin sie starb mit 76 Jahren
in Paris nach langer Krankheit auf einen
Schlag berühmt wurde sie 1969 durch
eines der erotischsten Lieder aller
hipste und unkonventionellste paar ihrer
Zeit ihre gemeinsame Tochter die
Schauspielerin Charlotte ganz Buch mit
den Frankreich ähnlich geliebt wie ihre
Eltern
die ganze Familie gehört quasi zum
kulturellen Inventar der Nationen
es ist ein Skandal als sie dieses Lied
ins mikrohaucht ein Skandal der John
bürkin ihr Leben lang begleitet und mit
sergesburg verbindet
dabei ist Jane Birkin viel mehr als die
Frau deren Freizügigkeit provoziert
virtueller Plausch in ihre Wohnzimmer
über ihr Leben als Muse Musikerin
Modeikone
auch wenn ich es eigentlich gar nicht
glauben mag aber ja es schmeichelt mir
mit Anfang 20 kommt Jane Birke nach
Paris und startet ihre Karriere als
Schauspielerin in mehr als 40 Filmen
wirkt sie mit liebt es sich immer wieder
neu zu inszenieren und wird schnell zu
beliebtesten Britin der Franzosen nach
der ein Luxuslabel sogar eine Handtasche
benennt die birkenberg
drei Töchter hat Jane bürkin von drei
verschiedenen Männern die berühmteste
ist Charlotte im 75 lebensjahr ihrer
Mutter dreht sie einen Dokumentarfilm
über sie Einblicke in die Beziehung der
beiden Frauen
dahinter steckte der Wunsch sich meiner
Mutter zu nähern ihr Fragen zu stellen
sie anzuschauen eine Intimität zu
schaffen
[Musik]
im gleichen Jahr bringt Jan ein Album
heraus ebenfalls sehr persönlich
schmerzhafte Erinnerungen etwa an den
Tod einer ihrer Töchter so wie Texte
über schöne intensive Momente
jahrelang geht Jane Birken auch mit den
Liedern von sergeance
über den Tod hinaus
[Musik]
schrittdämon und
ich weiß ganz genau wenn ich mal sterbe
dass das überall laufen wird ich kenne
mein Lied für den Schluss das ist doch
nicht schlecht
[Applaus]
Zufälle müsste man umarmen denn sie
könnten das Leben verändern hat sie
einst gesagt Jane Birkin hat das Leben
umarmt
und von uns gibt es jetzt noch den
Ausblick auf die nächste Woche Björn
Waldner hat einige wichtige Termine
zusammengestellt
[Musik]
ab Dienstag wird sich das
Bundesverfassungsgericht mit der
Bundestagswahl vom September 21 in
Berlin befassen wegen der zahlreichen
Pannen hatte der Bundestag mit den
Stimmen der Ampel eine teilwiederholung
beschlossen die Wahlprüfungsbeschwerde
der Union soll Klarheit bringen muss
doch in mehr Berliner Wahlbezirken neu
gewählt werden und sind auch
Direktmandate betroffen
am Donnerstag wird die
Fußball-Weltmeisterschaft der Frauen in
Australien und Neuseeland eröffnet 64
Spiele an neuen Spielorten wird das
geben erst der Gegner der deutschen wird
am 24 Juli Marokko sein im Stadion von
Melbourne wird die Mission Titelgewinn
starten zu sehen hier im ZDF
am Sonntag wird in Spanien ein neues
Parlament gewählt dem sozialistischen
Ministerpräsidenten Sanchez droht dabei
eine Niederlage gegen seinen
Herausforderer Echo der konservative
könnte ihn zusammen mit der
rechtsaußenpartei-box Ablösen der
Rechtsruck wäre eine Zäsur für Spanien
mit Folgen auch für die EU
und jetzt noch der Blick auf die
Wetteraussichten morgen gibt es im
Nordwesten und Westen Schauer am alten
Rand auch Gewitter sonst ist es trocken
und zeitweise sonnig die Temperaturen
erreichen Höchstwerte zwischen 21 und 30
Grad in den nächsten Tagen gelegentlich
Schauer am Alpenrand Gewitter dabei
werden maximal 19 bis 32 Grad erreicht
das war es von uns an diesem Sommer
Sonntagabend mit krimin geht's gleich
weiter und die nächsten Nachrichten
und hier erwarten Sie morgen abend
Christian Sievers und Hanna ganz genau
[Musik]